bonjour à tous on parle toujours
énormément de smartphones qui coûte cher
de smartphones à 700-800 plus de 1000
euros même aujourd'hui je faire linverse
je vous parlais d'un smartphone qui
coûtent pas cher je vous parlais d'une
fosses x lite qui est un produit qui
coûte moins de 131
[Musique]
voici vous connaissez cette marque n'est
fausse sortie un produit qui s'appelle
le ix en light qui est vraiment pas cher
aura effectivement d'avoir une fiche
technique de dingue ça pète le
smartphone avec de la puissance à gogo
mais par contre ça peut être un bon
compromis
quand on veut un smartphone qui en tout
cas sur le papier a l'air d'être de
bonne qualité qui vous permet de relever
vos e-mails d'avoir des applications
quelques petits jeux pas trop gourmands
de faire quelques souvenirs et tout ça
pour effectivement moins de 130 euros
donc soit faire dans cette vidéo c'est
que on va l'ouvrir on va regarder un peu
ce qu a dans le ventre
et puis on va le tester et ensuite je
vous dirai ce que j'en pense d'ailleurs
je vous invite dès maintenant à me dire
si vous le connaissez
si vous connaissez la marque défaut si
vous connaissez ce x lite s'il peut vous
intéresser
donc vous marquez tout sans le
commentaire et d'ailleurs si ce produit
vous intéresse je vous ai mis un lien
dans la description pour aller trouver
un tarif encore plus intéressant on va
tout de suite commencer par un déballage
et on va regarder effectivement ce qui
est dans la boîte
est ce que ce produit a dans le ventre
donc laissez moi vous présenter le nez
fausse x1 lite on va commencer tout de
suite par ouvrir un petit peu ça voir
comment il est fichu voir si il est
intéressant oui non non que ce qui a
dans le ventre
attention voilà où je mets un peu trop
secouer voilà la bête qu'est ce qu'on a
à l'intérieur on a une protection
d'écran à mettre sur le dessus alors ça
c'est vrai qu'en règle générale on ne
trouve pas et ça c'est plutôt
intéressant très bon point le produit en
lui même n'est fausse alors on va hop
prendre un peu se produit dans la main
la voilà la bête alors c'est vrai qu'il
est léger en termes de prise en main
envoyé ça tient plutôt bien
c'est plutôt pratique plutôt pas mal
foutu ce côté plastique info effet métal
et il fait son petit effet l'écran en
verre bon c'était plutôt bien on laisse
le design voyait très très très standard
vous avez ici votre petit haut parleur
votre caméra à l'avant des petites
touches de navigation qui ont été mises
en bas sur le côté le bouton volume
ici vous avez le bouton on off on croit
réussi à par des haut-parleurs stéréo
mais vous avez en réalité que haut
parleur mono du mini usb pour brancher
faut savoir pour aussi rajouter une
carte micro sd qui peut aller jusqu'à
128 go de stockage si vous avez des
besoins parce que vous avez 16 giga de
stockage à l'intérieur votre capteur
d'empreintes digitales à l'arrière votre
flash votre appareil photo ici 13
mégapixels avec une ouverture f 2.0 d'un
point de vue esthétique je trouve que
c'est un produit qui fonctionne bien et
puis surtout il a ici le port jack ou
non non je trouve que c'est plutôt pas
trop mal alors maintenant on va regarder
le reste de la boîte voir un petit peu
ce qu'il ya à l'intérieur vous avez ici
effectivement mais votre accessoire pour
pouvoir sortir votre carte sim la
direction de conformité les notices la
garantie le démarrage rapide et des
écouteurs youpi tralala avec le bouton
volume très bien qui vous servent
également pour vos communications
téléphoniques
le câble de recharge ici l'adaptateur up
bin plutôt pas mal complet complet
intérieur plastique bon c'est qu'il ment
ça fait un peu et pas très premium comme
audi s'introduit coûte moins de 130
euros donc va pas lui demander la lune
donc maintenant ce qu'on va faire c'est
qu'on va l'ouvrir et puis on va regarder
un petit peu comment ça se passe à
l'avant vous avez un appareil photo 5
mégapixels avec un grand-angle de 84
degrés
les vidéos sont du full hd c'est à côté
design on voit qu'il ya un bord à ses
fins vous avez si un effet incurvé je
sais pas si vous le voyez bien que je
trouve moi vraiment vraiment sympa en
tout cas j'ai vraiment plutôt bien fait
processeur c'est un média tu écopes
d'accord mt 6752 giga de ram une puce
graphique mali t800 60 mp de 16 giga de
stockage au niveau de l'écran c'est en 5
pouces hd 1280 par 720 p 293
cette paix pays une dalle y ps et du lcd
un écran qui occupent 68% de la face
avant en dimensions effet 142,6 71,2
petite profondeur de 8 5 mm 138 g à
l'intérieur vous avez une batterie de
2550 milliampères heures il tourne sous
android 7.0 avec une surcouche n f unis
2.0 mais s'en va le regarder ensemble et
le fabricant c'était publiques des pays
qui est connu pour être présent sur le
marché du w de l'âne
alors il existe effectivement en gris
ciel c'est le modèle que j'ai là mais
également couleur dorée alors on va
commencer par allumer la bête et y
bonjour les fausses welcome alors
english note english veille
bonjour on voit qu'effectivement les
bandes en bas on était vraiment optimisé
pour vous ayez ici des petits boutons
retour des boutons de navigation plutôt
bien pensé c'est pas mal fichu
maintenant ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on
va regarder un petit peu ce qui se passe
du côté de l'appareil photo pour voir
cet appareil photo est intéressant oui
ou non là on va filmer l'arrière alors
effectivement ici c'est compliqué de se
rendre compte on n'a pas des super
conditions de luminosité caméras
professionnelles panorama ralenti time
lapse professionnel qu'est ce qui va
nous proposer on a un iso réglable où on
peut monter jusqu'à 3000 mon avis mieux
vaut éviter
on a pas mal de possibilités sur le de
réglage le mode panorama les time lapse
bon on voit qu'on effectivement les
grandes fonctionnalités de base on a
différents filtres de couleurs call
chauffe roanne et moi on a une
possibilité d'avoir du hdr en switch sur
la caméra avant mais c'est très bizarre
ça lis énormément on regardera plus en
détail tout à l'heure où on va faire un
test incomplet de de ce côté là j'ai
l'impression que c'est hyper rallye
c'est donc là ce que vous propose tout
de suite c'est d'aller faire un test en
extérieur de ce nouveau smartphone voire
un petit peu la caméra est ce qu elle un
bon rendu au niveau de la photo un
moment
au niveau de la vidéo alors on va pas
rester hyper longtemps parce que dehors
il fait très froid il ya de la neige je
tourne on est en hiver mais bon on n'a
pas peur on y va quand même on va tester
la caméra arrière la caméra avant les
photos on va voir dans les conditions de
basse luminosité dans des conditions de
bonne luminosité qui offre un petit
débrief après donc la jetant des
conditions qui sont un petit peu sombre
il ya pas de stabilisation donc ça
risque un peu tremblé
j'ai des bottes et vous allez comprendre
pourquoi
[Musique]
dimanche le temps ici c'est l'hiver dans
mon jeu tourne dehors et il fait quand
même très très froid il doit faire
quelque chose comme je sais pas héros de
green et j'ai encore un peu tout à leur
tête un petit peu moins donc on va
filmer deux trois trucs on va faire
quelques photos l'emmener sur la caméra
arrière la 13 mégapixels et on va
regarder si le rendu est bien ou pas du
tout donc la regarde et hop je
m'approche il n'y a aucune stabilisation
celle de faire vraiment doucement le
focus est ce qui se fait en se
rapprochant petit peu ah ouais le focus
est bien là je suis vraiment très très
près ça fait vraiment des trucs pas trop
mal la lumière se règle assez rapidement
c'est pas mal ça permet de faire des
bons souvenirs de régler la luminosité
de la montée de la b c c'est vrai que
c'est assez satisfaisant de ce côté là
maintenant je sens la caméra vend
toujours bien évidemment en extérieur je
trouve que ça lisse un peu sa liste un
peu la peau c'est assez bizarre
le rendu mais bon donc on va faire la
même chose sur la caméra avant de
regarder si le rendu est assez propre
pas et aérien la neige le froid ça va
c'est pas trop mal c'est propre
après je vous le dis une fois de plus on
est sur un produit qui coûte moins 130
euros on va pas lui demander la lune
maintenant faire un test en passant d'un
extérieur bien éclairer un intérieur
sombre prendre un petit peu comment ça
réagit commencer la transition
aïoli va rentrer voilà la lumière la
lumière je me suis les pieds forcément
la neige on avance ici alors là je suis
un peu la veuve de cuisson avec la
mairie arrière je ne vois pas ici c'est
quand même souvent à lorient une petite
lumière mais c'est très sombre
donc voilà on va faire exactement le
même exercice maintenant mais sur la
caméra avant sur la 5 mégapixels je suis
en extérieur il ya toujours de la neige
il fait toujours froid et on va rentrer
pour voir un petit peu ce que ça dit
allez on y va entre même rituel
je me suis
c'est dégueulasse mais là c'est tout de
suite sombre ne bon franchement je ne
crois que ça fait quand même la faire
c'est ce qui est très bizarre c'est que
la wii le grain de peau comme il est
bizarre il ya beaucoup de bruit
forcément sur l'image le grain de peau
est assez lisse et c'est très très très
bizarre mais bon voilà fois de plus sur
un produit pas très cher donc pour que
ça fait là faire bon d'un point de vue
photo c'est pas extraordinaire mais
c'est normal ça on s'y attendait ce que
je regrette mais ce qui me paraît aussi
normal pour un produit de ce prix là
c'est deux pas du tout avoir de
stabilisation ce qui fait que dès que
vous bougiez un tout petit peu vous
voyez faire une photo ils vous marquent
ne bougeait pas du tout pour avoir de
bonnes photos c'est un peu effectivement
ce qu'on peut reprocher ce produit là ce
qui fait que pour la photo ça va être
très compliqué d'avoir des clichés
permettent si ce n'est deux pas du tout
bougé d'un petit centimètre
si ce n'est de le poser qu'allez vous
puissiez effectivement avoir une bonne
photo mais si vous voulez faire des
photos à la volée claque un peu
rapidement à mon avis faut oublier ça
marchera pas du tout bon le cmfi c'est
pareil
lorsque vous avez une bonne luminosité
que ce soit la caméra arrière où la
caméra avant ça fonctionne ça fait le
job
dès que vous baissez en luminosité salga
tout de suite un petit peu chaotique
ça me paraît aussi normal la caméra
avant temps ça vraiment lycée vous avez
quelque chose de trop lisse et hummel
soupçon d'avoir un espèce de fontain de
tata daniel a fait un truc très très
très très bizarre
une fois de plus je vous le dis c'est un
produit coûte quand même moins 230 euros
donc je trouve que pour son prix il fait
le job c'est pas dingue mais ça marche
il ya un proc est positif avec le
smartphone choco c'est le déverrouillage
rapide vous peser à peine votre doigt
est il des les rouilles immédiatement
c'est très réactif l'ont déjà annoncé
effectivement dans leurs spécifications
techniques un déverrouillage en 0,2
secondes puis vous assurer que c'est
vrai c'est vrai que ces pratiques
anciennes petites vibrations d'un point
de vue stockage à vous voyez j'ai filmé
de trois petites vidéos sur 16 giga g
9giga 46,2 disponible donc la promesse
des 16 giga elle est pas réellement là
que moi tout de suite que le système ne
prend 5,56 giga sur un smartphone de 16
giga je n'ai que 9giga 46 qui me reste
donc je pense que le fait de brancher
une carte microsd ce un vrai sens sur ce
smartphone là je suis à 51% de la
batterie il nous reste trois heures donc
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que si
60% je suis à 6 heures je suis pas sûr
je pense que c'est exponentiel
à voir en fonction de l'optimisation
si je passe en mode d'économie d'énergie
intelligente j'ai passé quatre heures ça
c'est positif
une fois de plus vous laissons un
smartphone d'entrée de gamme donc il
faut pas s'attendre à voir des
performances de dingue
alors au final parce que ce défaut 6e
nike est un bon smartphone oui ou non
pour moi pour le prix ça marche c'est un
bon smartphone il fait la faire il vous
permettra effectivement de passer des
coups de fil et d'avoir des applications
pas trop gourmande éviter les jeux
dernière génération éviter les choses
qui demandent trop de ressources que de
toute façon ça ne tournera pas bien
dessus
si vous voulez un smartphone pour aller
sur les réseaux sociaux pour envoyer
recevoir des emails pour naviguer sur
internet pour avoir quelques petites
applications pas trop gourmande pour
faire des petites photos souvenirs mais
en cherchant pas avoir particulièrement
de la qualité pour moi ce smartphone à
moins de 130 euros il fait la faire il
va pas vous offrir des performances de
dengue vous n'allez pas avoir une
autonomie complètement folle
mais vous allez avoir un petit produit
avec un design qui fait son effet qu'il
est plutôt sympa sur un android 7.0 pour
moi ça marche ça fonctionne est ce qu'au
final de telles d'une fosses x lite est
réussi pour moi il a passé le test
intéressant
dites moi vous ce que vous en pensez ce
qu'un smartphone comme celui ci pourrait
vous intéresser c'est vrai comme je le
disais au début de la vidéo
à l'heure où les smartphones deviennent
de plus en plus cher on passe les 1000
euros alors sur des produits haut de
gamme c'est tout autre chose qu'on parle
pas du tout du même produit sur du
galaxy note 8 sur 2 l'iphone 10
on arrive vraiment sur les prix qui sont
très haut même sur le milieu de gamme on
va cogner sur les tarifs autant autour
du 450 500 euros donc des petits
produits comme celui-là d'entrée de
gamme qui font affaire qui marche bien
me semble plutôt intéressant pour
effectivement des personnes qui n'ont
pas particulièrement de prétention au
niveau de leur smartphone dites moi vous
ce que vous en pensez
est ce qu'il pourrait vous intéresser
oui non est-ce que vous avez des
smartphones comme le défaut 6 light est
ce que ce produit pourrait faire la
faire vous invite comme d'habitude à
mener c'est des jolies pousse à vous
abonner parce qu'on a toujours tc plein
de nouveaux produits il ya plein de
tests à venir plein de nouveaux
smartphones plein de nouveaux produits
tech
restez connectés laissez-moi des pouces
abonnez vous
blier pas vous êtes les meilleurs quant
à moi je vous dis à très bientôt
[Musique]